in case you hadn't heard we have a live
look across the fabulous las vegas strip
but
yeah there will be no fireworks tomorrow
night
and we're kind of calling this the
in-between day it was kind of windy
yesterday and it's for sure going to be
windy tomorrow
but right now we're at 40 degrees with a
couple of clouds humidity is about half
of what it was at this time yesterday
a little breeze out of the northeast at
eight miles per hour so we're going to
be checking your neighborhood
temperatures here in a second
we are just watching and waiting for
that next round of clouds and wind as
early as tonight but certainly during
the day tomorrow
mid 40s 40 by 9 not bad a little bit
breezy at noon with a 50 degree reading
and then 54 for the afternoon high with
a few more clouds
should be 50 for you by 6 p.m a quick
check of your weather headlines here's
what we're talking about increasing
clouds and wind no rain
going to be very windy tomorrow and
we'll also have the forecast for the
first weekend of 2021